the next game is called most likely -
welcome to The Avengers end games all
right Avengers we'll give you examples
you vote on the fellow Avenger that best
fits each scenario here we go who is the
most likely to make you laugh in the
middle of the scene all right 500 points
to runner for using all of them
Hemsworth who'd you pick Mark Ruffalo
and why does he make you laugh because
she we don't we don't find that I said
he does an amazing squat thrusts oh yes
give it to us Jeremy give us your warm
up will ya who is the most likely to
stop to read a lost dog poster oh my god
no problem there everyone hick tevin's
he has a lost dog someone somewhere lost
their dog - Chris yes Oh Facebook pages
dogs okay which one of you is the most
likely to be the MVP at trivia night
Hemsworth why downy I know there's a
whole lot of strange useful and useless
facts really yeah I'll take a pilot why
Ruffalo I feel like he knows a whole lot
of useless something like I know he's
gonna know the lyrics so like somewhere
he's at all
I'm sorry we're losing the audience we
have to move on all right here we go
last question who is the most likely to
get mixed up in a pyramid scheme for
Hemsworth's
and to Ruffalo's regala wall he's just
sort of sweet and trusting
[Music]